book
book review book book review book
book review
we're back baby we're back at last i
read book
now i tell you
first off we have i'm a cat by
soseki natsume it's a japanese writer
who spent some time in england and then
he came back and then he published this
in a magazine only i think the first
chapter he wasn't planning to make it
into this
beast that it is today but people liked
it so much that he kept publishing it
and uh yeah maybe that's how you're
supposed to read it just like in parts
here and there it is the story told from
a cat that's what i knew about it going
in and it's supposed to reflect on the
meiji period in japan which is
transitional period between the
westernization of japan at least that's
what i thought so i made one of these to
make it
simple so this is what i read what i
expected some weird major period stuff
you know some commentary about it uh
some cat stuff some sexy cats maybe i
don't know the cat's name is chibi so i
expected like a cute little chibi cat uh
here's what i got
i wonder if anyone's read this book is
actually going like yeah yeah that's
about right
so we have uh some boomer
hitting on his wife this pretty much
summarized it right here the cat kind of
just glancing
we got some jam we got a fat cat we got
angry uh japanese men and something
about a glass bowl i don't really get it
guys check out new g fuel while we're at
it so this book is a satire it's a very
old satire but that doesn't stop it from
being enjoyable just like donkey shot or
any other book that is well written you
know the fact that this is so sicky's uh
first novel is incredible because it's
you know it's up there after reading
this it feels like a hidden classic like
a hidden gem uh that's what i thought at
least because i've never heard about it
before and i've done that mistake in the
past where just because i haven't heard
of a book before
that doesn't mean no one else has
i'm like no one's talking about this
book with a nobel prize award writer but
uh no that's not the case but i i did
look into it and uh it clearly left an
impact on uh in japanese culture so the
japanese title is wagahai neko so i am a
can wagahai being a pronoun that i i
thought is so unusual that it doesn't
normally exist so
bowser uses it for example here
referring to himself in high regard same
with the the cat in persona 4. so seki
also is depicted in the anime voice
something i don't remember and he's also
in phoenix friday's attorney
look at it uncanny so he clearly left an
impact on on japanese culture uh what's
the book about then well it's about a
bunch of characters mainly just speaking
to each other that's
pretty much it there's no real story and
it's chibi the cat who just observes
these characters communicating uh the
main character is chibi's owner which is
mr sneeze uh there's his wife mr sneeze
there's beau champ the poet or the
artist there's cold moon the scientists
and then there is waver house the
[ __ ] the prick and there's a couple
others too but i love the names of the
characters by the way they're so good
the story is something about a burglary
and they steal their jam mr sneeze
complains about his wife constantly
he goes to report the crime and then a
bunch of kids start being annoying and
then it ends really bleakly and sadly
story the story is not the most
interesting thing here where this book
shines is really when the characters are
communicating and talking about
different subjects or sharing different
ideas and anecdotes
uh it's highly allegorical and it's
feels like you're almost like a stage
play where everyone is interacting in
the same space in this room talking to
each other and it's being observed by
the cat and to me
that's one of the reasons why i enjoy
reading so much because you can immerse
yourself in discussion and topics and
ideas that transpires time and
culture and place you feel like you are
there contemplating the same thoughts
that the characters are and being part
of the discussion almost and it's just
i don't think there's any other medium
that can properly do that i feel like
this book style of writing reminds me of
dostoyevsky a lot i remember there's a
part in dostoevsky's the idiot where
they are talking about public execution
and uh i remember reading that and just
feeling so part of it and contemplating
this weird concept that we used to have
in a way i never would have thought
about before and i mean obviously it's
not like it's just random things but i
think that's what makes reading fun to
me i don't necessarily care that much
what happens to characters and and
different things like that i think it's
more fun to share ideas and that this
book is packed with that and especially
with the the idea of the execution this
book talks about the mechanics of
hanging very similarly for for a great
length and you know it's not like i went
in wanting to read about that but it was
very interesting and fun to follow and
nevertheless the book is also obviously
commenting about a lot of western
literature and culture which i find very
fun to hear a japanese perspective on
there was a story that i've even brought
up on my own and with on this channel
which is the story of the ancient greek
story of the writer that
tried to escape his prophecy that he was
going to die inside a house i don't know
if you guys remember watch the video but
it's so funny i think they said in the
book that he was a writer though that he
went out to write to avoid dying but
then there was an eagle flowing by who
wanted to drop a turtle that he was
holding onto a rock to smash open his
shell while he thought he saw the
rider's thick head
because according to this book riders
are just so thick-headed
he dropped the turtle on the head and
that's how the writer died a lot of
random stuff like that being shared in
this book which i i don't know i really
enjoyed that i thought it was fun i
think a lot of people probably at least
what i expected too is you know being
more focused on the cat uh there are
some bits here and there where the cat
describes typical cat-like behavior like
how why they watch themselves a certain
way or what they do for exercise or why
they meow and other cat-like behavior
but it's explained in a sense that if
there was a human explaining it with
perfect logic even though there's these
uh things that make no sense why cats do
and i
probably at least
uh from a human perspective at least you
still get to follow it and those bits
are great i really enjoyed those and i
think that's another reason why i enjoy
entering the mindset of this cat is very
fun this kind of crazy introspection
where what they're saying doesn't really
make sense but you're still in their
mind following it so it's still fun
anyway so yeah you just follow the
characters along in this book with
different small events happening here
and there there's not much to talk about
i think uh you know i gave some examples
of it it finishes very bleakly and
darkly about predicting the future of
japan and their culture with this this
shift that they're going through uh that
there will be no marriage in the future
which there's certainly less of and that
the rise of individualism is the cause
of this which is definitely a case
considering this was written 100 years
ago but then again i don't know you know
maybe the signs were already there back
then and that everyone in the future
will commit suicide which i'm thankful
hasn't happened at least but you know
it's definitely a problem
i would rate this book
four out of five very good i would be
cautious to recommend this book though i
think there's a lot of other books i
think that you can read before it but if
you haven't heard of in then uh yeah
maybe someone to check out next book we
have quite random actually it's uh zero
to one by peter thiel which is a
billionaire investor in paypal or
creator founder uh early investor in
facebook that's what i knew at least i
know he's the guy that sued gawker into
non-existence he's a controversial
figure but i think most billionaires are
to be fair my point is i don't really
know much about him besides that this
book was recommended to me by a friend
and i
have no interest in what it's about but
i thought it's fun to read different
stuff sometimes i sometimes when i get
into reading i don't really care what
i'm reading it's like yeah sure i'll
check that out it's true well whatever
this is the book on startups it says
notes on startups but as far as i
understand this is like the bible of
startups according to people and i guess
that's a topic that i'm not necessarily
that interested in most things i hear
about startup sounds kind of
cringeworthy and horrible and that whole
culture of silicon valley just seems uh
something i don't i don't like and even
though i you know i didn't really find
myself like oh hey
while reading it when i was writing down
my thoughts on the book i they all
tended to be quite negative which and
i'm not entirely sure why anna but i
think it's just the overall culture
around these type of things that
probably makes me look at it
in an unfair light i'm not saying this
is a bad book by any means but
just i feel like i skipped a couple of
steps maybe i should explain what the
book is sorry
i guess that's the thing the book isn't
very structured it's just random ideas
kind of here and there sprinkled out it
almost feels like peter is holding back
with a lot of things i think he's a
little crazy but he doesn't want to let
people know how crazy he is i i
definitely felt like he was holding back
reading this but their main gist of this
book and if i had to summarize it with
one thing is that okay what i read zero
to one what i expected a bunch of money
stuff and
i have no idea what i expected to be
honest i just put right into it what i
got was uh something about the unabomber
ai monopolies and founders being
important kind of random right that's i
guess that's what i meant with there's a
lot of just random thoughts that i think
he's interested in
being shared the main gist of this book
is the idea that if you want to go from
zero to one if you want to a startup
that really makes it a the banger you
want to come up with something that
isn't just replicating what other
businesses are doing but something
that's unique in a sense that it highly
stands out he starts off by making a
case for monopolies which i thought was
interesting at least i don't know if i
agree with it but it's fun to hear
different thoughts you know most people
were all taught growing up that
monopolies are bad and
it's better for competition if there's
many businesses according to peter what
this just does is that it squeezes uh
companies drive for making a profit and
that prohibits them from doing bigger
ideas and bigger things you know
businesses like restaurants and
businesses like uh
airlines have famously
really low profit margins because
they're so competitive um so even though
they're massive businesses there's not
much else you can do for that i guess
there's a case there
you know we're still flying the same
airplanes
from like from the 70s right hasn't been
any innovation and change maybe that's a
symptom of it i just a random thought in
my head but then again they buy the
planes from other companies so i'm not
sure i don't know but that's an example
of of it he brings up google as a secret
monopoly if you ask google hey are you a
monopoly you can't be a monopoly google
just go like hey
yahoo you want to go
yeah who exists okay i'm not a monopoly
but that's there's like alta vista right
there you guys can check it out so it is
google has monopoly it just uh
doesn't want anyone to know about it and
that makes it possible for google to do
a bunch of different things and whether
that's good or bad i think is not very
clear at least and the way to become a
monopoly like google is to have a
product that is just so good that you
are not going to want to go anywhere
else which is pretty much the case you
know we use google because there's they
are by far the best option because they
invested an ungodly amount of becoming
that product i think probably the more
interesting thing in the book if there's
one thing i had to take from it is the
idea that if you want to create a
business that goes from zero to one like
a business that makes it you have to
answer peter thiel's question that he
asks if you want to hire someone which
is what is one view you hold on an
important matter shared by a few other
people i'm not sure entirely if that was
the quote what is something that you
know that other people don't i guess you
could phrase it and if you can answer
that then you have the foundation of a
business that could really make it big
obviously airlines restaurants
wherever there is they will always be
profitable businesses and very
successful in these areas but the
businesses that really take off and you
make a ton of money on if that's your
goal they are the ones that don't just
improve but rather change the world kind
of like facebook did which peter was an
early investor in same with paypal
really paypal's goal i think was to
become an online currency that was the
original goal which i mean bitcoin came
along and did the job properly i think i
think it's a good example of something
that a lot of people knew but not most
people i think but a lot of people knew
there would be a digital currency in the
future obviously paypal becomes
something else but i think it's a good
example of that share of answering that
question of what is something that you
know that a lot of people don't and
that's how you create a successful
startup which i think yeah i probably i
agree with that
that's a good advice it's not bad but i
will have to rate it two out of five
because
just because i think he's holding back
and i think he is
it felt a bit random to be honest i
would like to hear more from peter i i
wouldn't mind hearing if you make
something else next book this is the
book that truly matters this is the book
that changed my life okay the useful
notch book how to tie the 25 plus most
practical notes nuts hell
yeah
this is what it's all about why did i
buy this book and not just look up
online i
i thought it could be nice for once to
not stare at a screen okay so i used to
sail a lot when i was younger and i used
to know all these nuts and then i
realized i completely forgot them i
gotta know my knots i gotta know my
knots check this out so in sweden the
way they would teach us this knot i
don't know what it's called in english
uh but we would have a lake right so if
you go with a boat and you want to tie
up your boat to a round-up or something
you have a lake and i would say here
comes the dragon and it goes he goes
under the lake
and then he grabs the bunny this is
supposed to be the bunny i'm like what
do you mean bunny that makes no sense
there's no bunny and then he go back
into the what do you mean
he didn't grab anything but there you go
it's a beautiful night i will never
forget you again
very strong
very strong knot i guess that's the
thing with the book it tells you the
philosophy of knots you know any idiot
can tie a knot but the goal is to tie a
knot that it's fast strong and also easy
to untie
that's the goal of knot i mean this is
the easiest knot but it's so good a lot
of times with boats you want to tie
around a cylindrical object beautiful
knot beautiful knot it's strong this way
it's strong this way
very good knot
love this knot i don't know what they're
calling english
i remember i'll never forget this night
you do the you do the thing
all right
it's if you want to tie two uh ropes
together that would always make us do
this
this is like one of the most basic knots
so pretty too pretty not actually will
hold
which is good if you want to extend your
thumb as we call it in sweden another
thing at the end of your rope if you're
sailing especially you don't want your
uh you don't want the rope to fall
through the winch or the uh the uh the
thing so you would always have to tie
something at the end of it and i would
always do the eight i love the eight
look at that eight that's a nice eight
that that rope ain't going nowhere you
know what i'm saying useful nuts guys
check it out book review last book guys
the remains of the day by casual ichigo
i've read another book from him in the
past called never let me go which was
kind of interesting it was a weird one i
also read the sleeping giant from him
which i hate i don't ever want to think
about that book but i decided to give it
another go because i saw the cover never
judge book by cover they saying well i
do it okay
i thought it looked nice minimalistic i
am an epic minimalist so what i expected
was that it's a story about a butler and
what i got was this and i will explain
this
that's the actual uh the original uh
cover for the book the book is old as
hell okay
i have no idea it's not like it matters
but it's more like i thought it was a
new book and it turned out to be old
book i don't want to read an old book
the way i knew it was an old book was
because uh i googled the title
eventually and this old movie showed up
and i'm like what they made it it's it's
made from a movie
it's like no the
the book came first
with anthony hopkins and emma thompson
so yeah the story follows a butler his
name is mr stevens and he reflects on
his past when he was serving as a butler
in the house called kensington hall i
think mr steven's care is anime level of
dedication to his work of being in a
butler it's all he cares about and he
aspires to be the greatest butler there
is and it's very fascinating to hear him
talk about how seriously he takes this
job as a butler and so how he this has
been something passed down from his
father who was also a butler and it's
seen as something very noble when people
really dedicate their life to their
craft but the more you read you start to
realize that uh
him wanting to be a butler the best
butler there is
has come with a great price of of a lot
of things uh for example his
relationship with his father is him
sacrificing his morals with who he
serves as a butler in the past and
maybe most importantly he sacrificed his
own happiness and and possibility of
finding true love these are things and
sacrifices that he's made but seems
completely oblivious to but as a as a
reader it's obvious this book is so damn
well written castle is a nobel prize
awarded author and it's very clear
reading this just because you feel like
you are reading the words from a butler
there's never a doubt in my mind that
that's the case it's written in this
most utmost british posh
eloquently spoken i can't do it but you
know what i mean like this super push i
feel like i should read this book in a
suit it's very captivating just just by
and by that um but going in finally on
what i meant with this picture is what i
feel a lot of times especially reading
his other book never let me go uh and
other british authors too like virginia
woolf i appreciate them and i appreciate
that they're great books but i can't
stand them i
i don't know why i even read them
because they are so dreary my god
everything is so difficult okay when
there's characters
and emotions between them that can't get
us expressed properly i appreciate
melancholy but this is just too much man
to say how you feel why can't you just i
understand these are complicated
emotions and the fact they're even able
to depict them in the fiction is
impressive but i hate it stop it it
reads like
that's what i get out of it okay
stop it three out of five i give it
three out of five
that's all the books for this month i
wanted to continue for next month i've
already started reading blood meridian
but then uh so i thought we'd do that
for next month because i can already
tell it's amazing but uh other ring came
out and i just dedicated my life to that
but i'm excited to get back into it this
is an what some people say it's the
greatest um american novel it said
western anti-western if that's
interesting to you but yeah excited for
more book review leave a like and smash
like and smash like for more and like
smash like and i see you smash like see
you next time bye bye